[موسيقى]
اصبحت المخيمات الفلسطينيه في سوريا احدى
نقاط المواجهه بين الثوار ومناصريهم من
الفلسطينيين وبين النظام ومواليه في
المخيمات وفي احدث التطورات اغلاق النظام
السوري مكاتب حركه حماس بالشمع
[موسيقى]
الاحمر
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في عنوانين
رئيسيين هل من الممكن ان ينق الفلسطينيون
بانفسهم عن المشهد الدامي في سوريا وما هي
مخاطر انخراطهم فيه مؤيدين ومعارضين
للنظام حاولت الفصائل الفلسطينيه في في
سوريا منذ اندلاع الثوره ضد نظام الرئيس
بشار الاسد الناي بنفسها عن الصراع بسبب
الطبيعه الحساسه للوجود الفلسطيني هناك
فهم لاجئون ينتظرون العوده الى بلادهم لكن
ذلك لم يمنع كثيرا من الفلسطينيين على
مستوى الافراد ان ينخرطوا في صفوف الثوره
كما ان بعض المخيمات خاصه تلك التي تؤوي
مشردين من احياء سوريه مجاوره تحولت منذ
اشهر الى اهداف لاله ظام العسكريه ليبدا
مسلسل دموي لا يبدو للاسف انه سيرى نهايه
قريبه تستضيف سوريا نصف مليون لاجئ
فلسطيني ينحدر اغلبهم ممن فروا من منازلهم
اثناء حرب عام
48 يتوزع هؤلاء في مخيمات تضمها مدن حلب
لاذق وحماه وحمص ودمشق ودرعا مقتضيات
الزمان والمكان تحث على التساؤل عن حال
فلسطيني المخيمات في سوريا في عهد ثوره
الحريه منذ اندلاع الثوره نات الكيانات
السياسيه الفلسطينيه في عمومها منظمه
وسلطه وفصائل بنفسها عما يجري في سوريا
غير ان بعض الفصائل الفلسطينيه بدت اقرب
الى صف النظام هناك كان في المقدمه
الصاعقه النسخه الفلسطينيه لحزب البعث
والجبهه الشعبيه لتحرير فلسطين القياده
العامه لكن نبض المخيمات شيء اخر تجاوز
الفص طائل ودخل على خط فعاليات الثوره على
اعتبار ان قضيه الحريه لا تتجزا الغضب
العارم الذي تلى مقتل فلسطينيين برصاص
القنص الاسرائيلي على الحدود مع الجولان
اسهم بشكل كبير في دخول مخيم اليرموك على
خط الثوره السوريه كان غضبا مما تدعى
الفصائل المتواطئ مع النظام السوري التي
نظمت مسيره العام الماضي الى الجولان في
ذكرى النكبه وراى كثيرون من ابناء المخيم
الاكبر في سوريا في ذلك محاوله لحرف
الانظار عن مجريات الثوره الشعبيه السوريه
في حين راى مراقبون في الامر مسعا للزج
بفلسطيني المخيمات في معترك الاحداث
السوريه وهو ما لم تتوقف الاطراف
الفلسطينيه جميعا عن التحذير من عواقبه
والواقع ان ثمه حرب استماله لهؤلاء
الفلسطينيين فقد باتوا طرفا ثالثا يتنازع
ولاءه طرفاها الصراع في سوريا وكثيرا ما
اودت تلك الاستقطابات الىى الصدام
المسلح فخيم اليرموك تحول اكثر من مره الى
ساحه قتال بينما تدعى الذراع الفلسطينيه
للقوات المؤيده للرئيس بشار الاسد
والمعارضين الذين يقاتلون للاطاحه به كما
تلقى نصيبه من قصف القوات النظاميه التي
تتحدث عن استهداف مواقع لمقاتلي المعارضه
داخل المخيم الواقع على مشارف دمشق يسري
حديث عن تلقي الجبهه الشعبيه لتحرير
فلسطين القياده العامه سلاحا من النظام
السوري الذي كان يحضر كل مظاهر التسلح
الفلسطينيه في المخيمات وحتى خارجها اما
الجبهه فتتهم الجيش السوري الحر بتسليح
جماعات فلسطينيه
لمقلتها الكل ينفي التهمه عن نفسه ويرفض
محاولات الزج بفلسطينيه المخيمات في نزاع
ثمنه دماء ودمار وتهجير لكن احدا لا
يستحضر معاناه سكان المخيمات الذين صار
النظام في دمشق يصفهم بانهم ضيوف يسيئون
الادب فهل انتهى من توظيف
قضيتهم لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
عمان الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ياسر
الزعاتره ومن بيروت الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي فيصل عبد الساتر نبدا معك سيد
ياسر الزعاتره وهذا السؤال هل لازال ال
بامكان الفلسطينيين النائي بانفسهم فعلا
عما يجري في سوريا ام ان سؤال مثل هذا
ربما تجاو وزه الزمن كونهم باتوا جزء من
المشهد السوري
بامتياز يعني ربما مرت القضيه قضيه
التعاطي تعاطي اللاجئين المخيمات
الفلسطينيه في سوريا بعده مراحل هي وسواء
اللاجئين انفسهم او الفصائل التي يعني
تمثل قطاعات عريضه من هؤلاء اللاجئين في
البدايه لم تكون الامور واضحه الى حد كبير
هناك كان بعض البعض يعتقد انها هبه شعبيه
ثم من قضي في هذه الاثناء ترددت الفصائل
الفلسطينيه وتردد الشارع الفلسطيني في
اتخاذ اي موقف نظرا للارث الدموي للنظام
والارث الامني البشع لهذا النظام وهذا
الارث يعرفه الفلسطينيون تماما كما تماما
كما يعرفه السوريون وبالتالي كانت هناك
محاوله للناي بالنفس عن الاحداث بمرور
الوقت وعندما تعسكرت الثوره اصبحت ال
المساله هنا ذات بعد فردي في بعض تجلياتها
بمعنى ان هنا هناك من بين الشبان
الفلسطينيين من اصبح ينخرط في بعض فعاليات
الثوره المسلحه وهذا لا يمكن ضبطه من قبل
اي من الفصائل الفصائل بدورها لا سما حركه
حماس بعد ان اتضحت يعني ربما منذ الشهور
الاولى اتخذت موقفا يعني حياديا نعم لكن
هذا الموقف الحيادي يجب ان ينظر اليه في
ظل وجود الحركه في حضن النظام السوري
وعندما تكون تاخذ موقفا حياديا هذا معني
يعني انه موقف جري الى حد كبير عندما يرفض
خالد مشعل على سبيل المثال ان يلتقي
بالرئيس السوري بعد شهور من الثوره لكي لا
تستغل الصور من قبله في حربه ضد الشعب
السوري هذا موقف يعتبر يعني جريء الى حد
كبير بعد ذلك اتخذت الحركه حركه حماس على
وجه التحديد قرارا بالانسحاب التدريجي من
الساحه السوريه اكراما للشعب السوري هي
بالتاكيد لا تنكر
ال الدعم الذي تلقته من النظام لكنها
بالضروره واكثر اث يعني لا تنكر ابدا
بالعكس هي اكثر وفاء للشعب السوري الذي
احتضنها وكان يعبر من خلال حبها عن حب
المقاومه وحب فلسطين وبالتالي هو وفاء
لهذا الشعب العظيم اراد الانحياز له
ولقضائك التي تستند اليها الحركه لابد ان
تدفعها في هذا الاتجاه المخيمات اللاجئين
بعد عسكره الثوره بدات يعني ت تنخرط شيئا
فشيئا في في هذا المضار ودا لانخراط سيد
ياسر دعنا نتحول لسيد فيصل عبد الساتر وقد
قدمت ربما تمهيدا عن رغبه الفلسطينيين في
سوريا فعلا بعدم الانخراط غير انه وكما
يبدو من خلال العديد من الخطوات سواء
القصف على مخيماتهم الاعتقالات سقط اكثر
من 500 فلسطيني يبدو ان النظام زج بهم زجا
في هذه المعادله
لماذا السؤال سؤال الي نعم سيد
فيصل نعم يعني اولا يعني هذا التقديم الذي
تفضل به ضيفك الكريم من من الاردن يعبر عن
وجهه نظر وهذه الوجهه النظر قد يعني يقبل
بها البعض وقد لا يقبل بها البعض الاخر
اعتقد ان الوفاء
لسوريا لا يكون للشعب السوري وحده وانما
يكون لسوريا سوريا هي دوله ونظام وشعب
واعتقد ان الشعب السوري لو لا كان لو لم
يكن هذا النظام هو الذي اسس ثقافه فلسطين
في داخل نفوس ابناء الشعب السوري لما
اعتقد ان الشعب السوري كان يحمل هذه
الثقافه اسوه بباقي الشعوب العربيه نحن
نعرف ان كثير من الشعوب العربيه انظمتها
كانت تتعامل مع القضيه الفلسطينيه بشيء من
الفظاظه وبشيء من ال يعني ال اللامبالات
بينما الواقع في سوريا مختلف تماما وصل
الفرد الفلسطيني في سوريا الى اعلى
المراتب على مستوى الوظيفه العا عامه بل
يعني ذهب البعض الى ان رئيس الاركان في
فتره من الفترات في الجيش العربي السوري
كان من الجنسيه الفلسطينيه اذا لم ي لكن
رغم ذلك سيد فيصل اعذرني هنا فقط افتح
قوسا لم يمنع الناطق باسم الخارجيه
السوريه من وصفهم ضيوف رغم كل هذه المناصب
وحتى قال بانهم ضيوف اساؤوا الادب
اي يعني اولا وصف الضيوف هذا بطبيعه الحال
لانه الحفاظ على قضيه الشعب الفلسطيني لا
يمكن لاحد ان يقول انهم اصبحوا ابناء
سوريا هم يتعاملون معهم على المستوى
الوظيفي كانهم ابناء الشعب السوري لكن على
مستوى القضيه بالتاكيد هم ضيوف هلا اذا
كان بعض اساءات الادب صدرت من بعض ال يعني
الحركات الفلسطينيه او بعض التجمعات
الفلسطينيه هذا لا يعني ان هذا موقفا من
كل الفلسطينيين الموجودين في سوريا وان
النظام هو الذي زج بالعنصر الفلسطيني في
الازمه انا اعتقد لا يعني في من خلال
مراجعه دقيقه لما يحدث الان في سوريا
محاوله الزج هذه تاتي من المعارضه المسلحه
بجميع اطيافها وجميع حركاتها هي التي
تحاول ان تست لكن هل يقل ان يبقى
الفلسطينييون سيد فيصل مكتوفي الايدي
ومخيمات تقصف بالطائرات ويعتقل منهم
الالاف وا ليس اخر تطور ربما الخبر الذي
ادعنا اليوم ومختلف وسائل الاعلام باغلاق
مكاتب حماس بالشمع
الاحمر يعني هل هو المطلوب ان يصبح
الفلسطيني جزء مما يحدث في سوريا يعني اما
ان يكون مكتوف الايدي اما ان يكون جزء من
المؤامره على سوريا اعتقد كلا النظرتين هي
نظره غير دقيقه يجب ان نحدد الامور بدقه
اكثر عندما نتحدث عن بعض البؤر التي
استفاد منها المعارضه المسلحه في بعض
المخيمات الفلسطينيه نحن نتحدث عن احياء
ونتحدث عن اشخاص محددين وعن جهات محدده
تريد ان تدفع بالشارع الفلسطيني الى ان
يكون جزء من الازمه لماذا لا ناخذ السواد
الاعظم من الفلسطينيين على سبيل المثال
هناك مخيم النيرب في حلب لم يكن جزءا مما
يجري في سوريا بل استطاع ان يكون خارج
مشهد الاطار الدموي الذي يحدث في سوريا
لماذا يراد لمخيم اليرموك وهو اكبر
التجمعات الفلسطينيه في سوريا ان يكون
جزءا من هذا الصراع لانه جاور على المستوى
الجغرافي احد اهم اكثر الاحياء في دمشق
ربما حراكا على المستوى الدموي وهو حي
التضامن وحي القدم وحي الحجر الاسود وحي
يلد من الشرق وص احول هذا التساؤل الذي
تطرحه السيد فيصل للسيد ياسر الزعتره
لماذا يراد لمخيم اليرموك تحديدا وهو يشير
الى نوايا مبيته ان يكون في اتون هذه
المعركه يعني قبل ان اجيب على هذا الجانب
اريد ان اقول ان هذه اللغه لغه تحميل
الجمال مائل للشعب الس للشعب الفلسطيني او
للاجئين الفلسطينيين في سوريا غير مقبوله
الفلسطينيون موجودين موجودين في سوريا قبل
ربما هذا النظام وعز الدين القسام يعني
كان مساهما في القضيه السوريه وسميت كتائب
عز الدين القسام باسمه قبل ان يولد حافظ
الاسد والذاكره الفلسطينيه لا لا لا تقول
بان بشار الاسد او النظام الاسد الابن وال
والاب يعني قد حمل كثيرا من الجمائل للشعب
الفلسطيني ربما السنوات الاخيره كان هناك
موقف ايجابي الى حد ما لكن ذاكره تل
الزعتر لازالت موجوده ذاكره حرب المخيمات
لازالت موجوده ذاكره التواطؤ في اخراج
منظمه التحرير والمقاتلين الفلسطيني من
لبنان وتلزيق المقاومه بعد ذلك لحزب الله
لحسابات سياسيه واستراتيجيه ايضا موجوده
وبالتالي الشعب الفلسطيني ليس قصير
الذاكره حتى يقال له هذا الكلام اما فيما
يتصل بدور مخيم اليرموك اولا مخيم اليرموك
اتسع وهناك يعني فعاليات سوريه و وسوريون
يسكنون في اطراف هذا المخيم وبالتالي من
الطبيعي ان ينخرط هذا المخيم في الثوره
عندما يجري تطييف الثوره عندما يجري
استباحه دماء السوريين ال الشعب الفلسطيني
في المخيمات وفي مخيم اليرموك عندما يرى
شقيقه السوري يقتل بدم بارد من قبل
الطائرات والدبابات لا يمكن الا ان يتحرك
في هذا الاطار لا يمكن الا ان يساعد
اللاجئين لا يمكن الا ان ينخرط بعض شبانه
في في في الفعاليات المسلحه الان جماهير
الامه غالبيه الامه باستثناء فئات معروفه
ومحدوده لها صلات بايران او تتبع النهج
الايراني غالبيه الامه تقف الى جانب
الثوره السوريه وغالب الشعب السوري ايضا
تقف الى جانب الثوره من الطبيعي والحاله
هذه وهؤلاء الخ اللاجئون الفلسطينيون في
المخيمات هم جزء من هذه الامه جزء من هذه
الكينونه التي انحازت الى الثوره التونسيه
والى الثوره المصريه والليبيه واليمنيه
ومن الطبيعي ان تنحاز الى الثوره السوريه
لا سما انها كانت الاكثر عطاء في الدم
والشهداء والاكثر سخاء والاكثر قدره على
على تجييش مشاعر الامه خلف قضيه الحريه
والكرامه التي يعني ارادها الشعب السوري
الشعب السوري لم يخرج ضد للا المقاومه ولا
الممانعه ولا ضد محور ايران هو خرج يطلب
الحريه والتعدديه والكرامه تماما كما خرجت
توانسه وال والمصريين واليمنيين وبالتالي
هذه اللغه لغه تحميل الجمائل غير مقبول
على الاطلاق وان ينخرط بعض الشبان
الفلسطينيين في الثوره الى جانب اخوانهم
السوريين علىق هذا الامر الطبيعي ومتوقع
ارج ارجو ان تبقى معنا سيد ياسر سنحاول
مواصله طبعا هذا النقاش ونطرح تساؤلات
اخرى لكن بعد فاصل قصير ابقوا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا الكرام
نتحول مباشره الى ضيفنا من بيروت السيد
فيصل عبد الساتر والسؤال ربما ايه الان في
هذا الشق الثاني من البرنامج يعني زج
بالفلسطينيين ام دخلوا طواعيه في هذا
اي الموضوع في الازمه السوريه وفي خضمها
السؤال الان ما مدى خطوره تواجدهم كطرف
كجزء كمشاركين في هذه الازمه
باعتقادك انا لازلت على فكره اساسيه ان
السواد الاعظم من الشعب الفلسطيني في
سوريا لن يكون جزءا من هذه المؤامره التي
تجري على حساب سوريا تحت شعار ثوره الحريه
والى اخره مفهوم الثورات اصبح مختلفا
تماما عما كنا نتكلم عنه منذ بدايه ما سمي
بثورات الربيع العربي عندما بدات الازمه
في سوريا بدا الامر ياخذ منعطفا اخر تماما
هذا الكلام الذي تفضل به ضيفك من عمان لا
ينم عن يعني استراتيجيه سويه في مقاربه
الامور اولا سوريا لم تحمل جمائل لا الى
الشعب الفلسطيني ولا الى كل القيادات
الفلسطينيه وهو يعرف ان السيد خالد مشعل
هو الذي طلب لقاء الرئيس الاسد والرئيس
الاسد هو لم يقبل هذا اللقاء ليس العكس
ابدا على ما اورده ويعرف تماما ان حماس
التي تلقت كل انواع الدعم من سوريا لا
اعتقد ان دوله في هذا العالم كانت تقدم
لحماس ما كانت تقدمه سوريا على كل
المستويات اي ويشهد على ذلك السيد خالد
مشعل وكثير من القيادات
الفلسطينيه ولا تزال بعض القيادات
الفلسطينيه تحمل هذا الوفاء ل الرئيس بشار
الاسد وعندما نتحدث عن سوريا انا لا اريد
ان اختص سوريا ببشار الاسد ولا بالرئيس
الراحل حافظ الاسد وعندما ذكر الشيخ عز
الدين القسام هو سوري وليس فلسطيني هو جاء
من مدينه جبله وهو الذي قاد ثوره طويله
عريضه في داخل فلسطين المحتله اذا الشعب
السوري تتاصل فيه ثقافه المقاومه جاء هذا
النظام ليعطي اكثر لهذه القضيه ابعادا
اخرى اما فتح دفاتر الماضي هو يعرف تماما
ان فتح الدفاتر ممكن ان ين ينطبق على جميع
الاطراف ممكن ان ينطبق على الرئيس الراحل
ياسر عرفات وعلى كل القيادات الفلسطينيه
التي تعاطت فيصل لا لا اسمحي لي اسمحي لي
اسمحي لي لا يمكن تناول الرئيس حفظ الاسد
بهذه الخفه في حلقه من نصف ساعه ثم نسكت
عندما نريد ان نتحدث عن دفاتر يجب ان
نتحدث عن دفاتر ما فعله الملك حسين في
الاردن بالفلسطينيين وما فعله اليمين
اللبناني بالفلسطينيين في لبنان لا نريد
نتحدث يعني هل هل العبره اذا ان يتبارى
الجميع بالتنكيل بالفلسطينيين ونحن نتحدث
هنا وارجو ان نحصر فعلا موضوع الحلقه حول
الثوره السوريه دعني اتحول سيد ياسر ساعود
اليك سييد فيصل عذرا حتى فقط نقسم الوقت
بطريقه فيها نوع من العدل التخوف الاكبر
الان سيد ياسر هل هو فعلا ربما من خراط
الفلسطينيين اللاجئين الفلسطينيين في هذه
المعركه الى جانب طرف او اخر او ربما ايضا
هناك تخوف اخر بدا يشير اليه البعض ربما
من اقتتال داخلي بين الفلسطينيين انفسهم
في
سوريا يعني اولا انا قلت انه عز الدين
القسام سوري وليس فلسطيني وهذا ما ما كان
مناط الاستشهاد فيما يتصل بالوضع الداخلي
في المخيمات الان هناك غالبيه فلسطينيه
تنحاز الى الثوره الضمير الفلسطيني في
الداخل الفلسطيني وفي الشتات كما هو
الضمير العربي والاسلامي منحاز بالكامل
الى الثوره السوريه هذه مساله لغه الوضوح
اذا كانت هناك حفنه من المرتزقه تقبل ان
تعمل في مضمار الشبيحه وجيش بشار الاسد
الذي يستبيح المدن وبما فيها المخيمات هذا
لا يعبر عن ضمير الشعب الفلسطيني هذه فئه
قبلت ان تلعب دور المرتزقه في الى جانب
الشبيحه الذين يستبيحون دماء الشعب السوري
ودماء الشعب الفلسطيني عندما نتحدث عن 550
شهيد الى الان من نصف مليون فلسطيني هذا
يعني انه بالنسبه والتناسب تصبح يصبح عدد
الشهداء قياسا بعدد السكان لا يختلف كثيرا
عن السوريين الذين سقط منهم حتى او ارتقى
شهداء منهم حتى الان حوالي 35 السؤال هنا
الذي يطرح سيد ياسر هذه الازمه لاما تعرض
مصير نصف مليون
فلسطيني الان الان الشعب الفلسطيني مستباح
كما هو الشعب السوري هذ الدبابات الثقيله
عندما تقصف والطائرات عندما تقصف لا تمي
من في الشارع بالامس قتل في في احدى
الحافلات تزامن او تصادف ان الموجودين في
الحافله كلهم من من من الفلسطينيين
واستشهدوا جميعا خلال ال 48 ساعه الماضيه
استشهد 30 فلسطيني في مخيم اليرموك وما
حوله بالتالي الان هناك حاله لا نستطيع ان
نقول ان هناك حاله من الانقسام في الوسط
الفلسطيني في سوريا هناك انحياز كامل
للشعب السوري وللثوره النبيله التي قدمت
بسخاء هناك حفله من المرتزقه قب قبلوا ان
يعملوا في اطار النظام وهؤلاء لا يعبرون
بالعكس حتى لا نستطيع ان نجزم ان هؤلاء
بالفعل فلسطينيون عندما يقال ان هؤلاء
يتبعون الجبهه الشعبيه القياده العامه هذا
لا يؤكده احد ربما يكونون من الشبيحه او
من عناصر الامن او الجيش السوري ودخلوا
الى المخيمات لنصره حفنه من الذين ينتمون
الى الجبهه الشعبيه القياده العامه
والصاعقه طبعا لا وجود لها وحتى الجبهه
الشعبيه هذه تنظيمات مجهريه ليس لها وجود
حقيقي في في الوسط الفلسطيني التنظيمات
الح الحقيقيه الموجوده في الوسط الفلسطيني
حماس وفتح والجهاد الاسلامي هذه لا يمكن
ابدا ان تتورط في نصره النظام ضد جماهير
الشعب السوري او ضد الثوره السوريه
النبيله وبالتالي هذا موقف فلسطيني نبيل
هذا تعبير عن ال هذا تعبير حقيقي عن
الوفاء للشعب السوري لانه سوريا لدى الشعب
الفلسطيني هي سوريا الشعب بشكل اساسي
سوريا الارض سوريا الوطن وليس سوريا بشار
الاسد ورامي مخلوف هؤلاء طارئ على الشعب
السوري وبالتالي تبقى سوريا حره كريمه
بشعبها الابي وهؤلاء وهذه هي التي ينحاز
لها الشعب الفلسطيني وبالم بالمناسبه
فلسطين جزء من سوريا الكبرى وعندما احتلت
فلسطين هي جزء من من سوريا وهي تعتز بهذه
النسبه وتعتز انها جزء من سوريا الكبرى
ولا يمكن ان تقبل بهذه التفرقه التي صنعها
سايكسبيكو وبالتالي من الطبيعي ان ينحاز
الضمير الفلسطيني كما هو الضمير العربي
والاسلامي الى ثوره نبيله خرجت تطلب
الحريه والكرامه ثم بدا هؤلاء الشبيحه
يصفونها بانها مؤامره وعميله مع ان العالم
كله يتامر عليها بما فيها امريكا
والصهاينه الذين ارادوا تدمير البلد من
اجل اشغاله بنفسه لعقود هناك مؤامره على
ثوره الشعب السوري وليس على النظام السوري
هناك حاله من التزوير المزمن نعم دعنا
نتحول لسيد فيصل عبد الساتر من بيروت هل
لازال بالامكان باعتقادك ان يخرج النظام
السوري الفلسطينيين من هذه المعركه التي
يخوضها ضد
شعبه اولا ليس النظام السوري من زج
بالفلسطينيين اعود واكرر ان هناك جماعات
تريد ادخال العنصر الفلسطيني جزء من
الازمه السوريه باي غرض من الجماعات وباي
غرض حتى نفهم ويفهم المشاهد دون تلميحات
نعم هناك جماعات واضحه جماعات واضحه من
المعارضه المسلحه السوريه كانت تستعمل
البيوت هناك جماعات اصوليه داخل الشعب
الفلسطيني لا يتوانى عن هويته الحقيقيه في
ان ما يحدث في سوريا له علاقه بهذه ال
بهذه الانفاس الاصوليه التي تريد ان
تستبيح كل شيء تحت شعار الاصوليه هذا
الامر بات معروفا في لبنان موجود في
الاردن موجود في سوريا موجود في مصر موجود
في كل المنطقه ويعني اريد ان اقول ان يعني
تحميل النظام في سوريا هذا الموضوع ويعني
القول بان الرئيس بشار الاسد وغيره من
الشخصيات امثال السيد رامي مخلوف طارئين
على الشعب السوري يعني اعتقد ان الذي يحد
من هو طارئ على الشعب السوري من هو يحدد
ايضا من هو طارئ على الشعب الفلسطيني الذي
كان يتغذى ويرضع من السوريين طيله اكثر من
20 عاما ثم جاء الان ليطعم في السور عليه
ايض جميل مره اخرى وتقول بانك لا تتحث
عن اسمحلي لماذا تقط عينني انا على الخصوص
هو تحدث عن الرئيس بشار الاسد طارئ على
سوريا كيف تقبلين مثل هذا الكلام ولا
تقبلين ان ارد ويكون هذا تح جما ليس انا
من يرد بل انت من يرد سيد فيصل انا ارد
اذا لا تقاطعيني حتى اكمل الفكره عندما
كان السيد خالد مشعل والجهاد الاسلامي
وفتح الانتفاضه والصاعقه وكل الفصائل
الفلسطينيه منذ اقل من سنتين وطله 20 سنه
الى الوراء كان هذا النظام واحى من
الديمقراطيه كان هذا النظام يعطي الشعب
السوري الحريه بكل انواعها اذا كانت
الفصائل الفلسطينيه جزء من هذا التامر على
الشعب السوري اذا كان هذا هو المقصود اما
التغني بالثورات وان هذا الشعب يريد
الثوره ويريد الحريه كلنا نريد الحريه لكن
ه الحريه لم يعد لها مدخل ومخرج الا بسفك
الدماء والقتل على الهويه واحداث المجازر
ثم القول ان النظام في سوريا هو الذي
يمارس وكان الجماعات الاخرى توزع الورود
والياسمين على مداخل مخي
ال اليوم الم يقتل الم يقتل الفنان محمد
رافع في دمشق اليوم لماذا قتل محمد
راسد سحول ربما في 20 ثانيه فقط حق الرد
للسيد ياسر الزعاتره على كل ما
ذكرت تقديري ان البعد الاخلاقي كثيرا ما
يغيب في هذا الخطاب الشعب السوري خرج يطلب
الحريه والكرامه وخرج بسلميه تامه كان
يهتف واحد واحد واحد لل الشعب السوري واحد
سلميه سلميه مكث شهورا
وهو ينزف دما غزيرا في الشوارع من دون ان
يطلق رصاصه واحده النظام هو الذي اضطره
الى عسكره الثوره بالعكس حتى معالم عسكره
الثوره الاولى هذه كانت بسبب النظام ولذلك
القول بان هناك مجموعات مسلحه وما الى ذلك
هذا عباره عن تزوير للحقيقه الشعب السوري
اضطر لحمل السلاح من ا عن السباح وهذا هذا
البعد ينساه هؤلاء اشكرك جزيل الشكر ياسر
ال ع الكاتب والمحلل السياسي كنت معنا من
عمان كما نشكر جزيل الشكر ضيفنا من بيروت
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي فيصل عبد الساتر
وبهذا مشاهدينا الكرام تنتهي هذه الحلقه
من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله
في قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد السلام
[موسيقى]
عليكم
ه